so the number 23 we have a two in the
tens place
so that two literally represents two
tens and we see it right over here we
have two groups of ten blocks this is a
ten
and this is a ten so this two
literally represents two tens one ten
and two tens
now this three is in the ones place
and it represents three ones we see them
right over here one two three blocks and
of course if you had three ones together
with two tens these two tens represent
twenty and these three ones represent
three so you get twenty three so let's
write that down so we could write down
that 23
23 is equal to two tenths
two
tens
plus three ones
plus
three
three ones
now what would happen if i added
20 to 23 let me do that
so let's say actually let me do
something more interesting let's say we
take 23
23 and to that we add 30.
so let's add
let's add
30.
three zero
three
zero so what is this going to be
well i start with 23 which i have
represented here and i'm going to add
30. 30 has 3 in the tens place so it
literally means i'm going to add 3 tens
and i'm going to add 0 ones so let me
add those 3 tens so
that's 110
this is
two tens
and then
that is three tens so i've added one two
and three tens here
so now
now
how many tens do i have
well i now have one
two three four five tens
and notice two tens plus three tens is
equal to five tens
so now i have
five tens
and how many ones do i have well i still
have those three ones and you could
think of it this way three ones plus
zero ones is still going to be three
ones
three ones so what's 23
what's 23 plus 30 going to be let me
rewrite it 23
plus 30
plus
is going to be equal to well five tens
we could just write that as a five in
the tenths place represents five tens or
fifty
and then we're going to have three ones
whoops let me do that in a different in
the ones color in that orange color is
the and three ones so 23 plus 30 is 53
you have two tens plus three tens give
you five tens three ones plus zero ones
is equal to three ones